we have some great guests in studio
these are our celebrity guests but we
have some surprise guests uh matt can we
get a little intro music please ladies
and gentlemen from the howard stern show
one of them is a
70 plus year old man he's got the arms
out today ronnie muntz
and the second one they call them
hollywood harmer and freddie fits right
in he's wearing a [ __ ] flannel just
like us jd
hello hello
now use this music and fight each other
yeah
we said before anything started that jd
would just walk in and giggle
uncontrollably and he did not disappoint
well i mean what are you gonna do he
never disappoints
you know i gotta say
i gotta say though jd in my life
you're the person whose name comes up
most as a name drop
from this show really
for real
there's a lot of like oh i saw jd oh
well jaden jd is a very popular guy like
we're giving them [ __ ] we're calling
them hollywood harmer but there's a
reason you have earned this nickname i
mean you have many celebrity friends
that you talk to online and both hang
out in person and stand us up for well
we did have a fun moment last night
because you know ronnie talks about like
when he comes out here a lot of the time
that you know a lot of people recognize
him because ronnie's a big deal and
that's true yeah and so yeah so we're
sitting at the restaurant you know it's
at the grove and it's outside and ronnie
sees it i don't know which one it was
but one of the twins one of the
oppenheim brothers from selling sunset
i'm selling sunset and ronnie's like i
just saw him on a show he got his car
done and ronnie like wanted to meet him
so i was like you know we'll play this
cool so he was inside he was doing his
thing and when he walked out i go uh hey
jason it's ronnie from the howard stern
show big fan and uh he totally big time
no he didn't gary he said hello he fist
bumped me he did yeah he
definitely did not fist bump you he gave
you the band wave he shoots you up like
i don't remember i don't remember him
approaching the table i don't even i
don't know
your eyes it was definitely a blow-off
it was very quick it was a blow-off it
was a blow-off definitely a blow-off but
he did fist-bump me